if you don't know who Donathan sharp is
he's considered a red pill Guru one of
the leaders in the Manis spere he touts
himself as somebody that young men
should emulate in terms of how they
should live their life well we did a
previous video in which uh it was
exposed that he's been lying about a lot
of his life like much of these red pill
people take a any man who marries a
woman past the age of 23 years old
you're getting leftovers but uh yeah
David listen man um I'm not trying to be
mean-spirited but you married a single
mom like post-wall women they get
married all the time but the men they
get married to are very low value
they're beta males they're pushovers
they're not real men they're not the men
that arouse these women so credits what
credits due uh this man makes fun of
other people's spouses and different
things like that claims he would never
date a single mom well somebody pulled
up his quote unquote girlfriend's
bankruptcy records CU those are public
records that anyone has access to and
they found some interesting information
Deon is one of just a few women I've
dated older women I've dated who didn't
have any kids when I met them but again
they're the exceptions um Devon is my
girlfriend she is not my wife we have
never been been married she is not a
single mother and we do we have not
adopted anybody I got a 13-year-old
niece that stays here at least twice a
week because Olivia she's 14 years old
now and she's dude she's a beautiful
girl she could and so as we now look at
her application on the screen and go to
the section describing her household it
states do you have
dependence yes does dependent live with
you yes dependent's age 10 years old
dependent relationship to dead or one
daughter I want to make something clear
here I don't care what kind of woman you
choose to be your girl be with who you
want to be you want to date a single
month I don't care what I don't like and
what I think is very laughable is you
run a course you have video clips making
fun of other men for dating single moms
and criticizing those women now keep in
mind that this also contradicts
everything Donovan sharp has taught his
audience about the types of women to
avoid going all the way back to his days
when he wrote for Return Of Kings to his
free ebook called 16 ways to immediately
disqualify her for a relationship where
he states that single mothers should be
avoided as they make for the worst
girlfriends wives and mothers I'll a
single bomb and yes listen I know single
bombs are bad and this and that and the
other but we all got to start somewhere
don't commit to them you've been married
before I have okay you've been married
before I got married young and I was
married for a very long
time you know for the 20s something
years before we met you know as an as an
adult you know for the 20 something
adult I met you when you were 32 uh you
are an older woman Devin my girlfriend
is an older woman okay yes my girlfriend
is an older woman she turned she turned
36 back in February I misled my audience
about Devon's age but I did that for
privacy purposes listen Dev is 45 every
day you get online and you lie about the
fact that that woman has a daughter that
the woman that you call your girl your
wife has a daughter and you not only are
you lying about it you lying about the
fact that your girl's old which is fine
but you lying about it while telling
other people to not wife up you Goods
that's what you you say uh what's up
guys uh it's your man Donovan sharp and
uh I need to share the link copy the
link give me two seconds guys I need to
send this okay guys this is it uh we are
going to get married I am now going to
give the uh camera to uh our guy here we
go all right we're
live no you going to turn it around
there you go you ready MH let's
go
[Music]
S I don't know if that's not the most
poetic thing
ever but a red pill wedding would be
filmed upside down he he did say uh turn
it around so I mean it
is you can't make this up that is that
is that is
poetry so this is a this is literally
titled a red pilled wedding
I can't all these high value men and
they still don't know how to not [__]
invert this [__] video they don't
know how to operate a camera I mean I
understand marriage isn't a big deal to
you guys but that's that's that's a skit
that's AIT they look like they're in a
hotel lobby that's a
skit hey
says orientation is locked where yeah
you can't do it inside and here we are
guys yo it's a l for the cameraman it's
a l for the editor that's his kid and
he's edited his own wedding that's his
kid all right let's that's his kid okay
let's
bro this would be a red pill wedding cuz
everybody I saw who in that audience was
just dude all right guys uh welcome to
uh Welcome to our wedding this is going
to be a very uh very sort of informal
thing um there is no uh what do they
call that an officient pass yeah I'm the
efficient okay I'm the efficient and I
run this so we're going to exchange Val
she's got a few words for me I've got
some words for her uh and then I will by
the power invested in me
sharp
she's I got a word for
her would you want to be my hoe and only
hoe for the rest of our
lives
[Applause]
Bud the heos people
clapping I refuse
I refuse to believe that's family and
friends CU I don't care how cringey and
red pill you are there is no way your
family friends would clap at that kind
of speech I think this got pay people to
be an
audience ready I'm
ready each day when we wake up we choose
one another you have taught me that the
r rent is due every day and not to take
things for granted the rent is due every
day and to not take things for GR this
is kid stop you can sh this sh each day
when we wake up we choose one another
you have taught me that the rent is due
every day and not to take things for
granted a healthy garden takes watering
prining attention in order to flourish
thank you for demanding the best of me
always I promise to stand beside you
walk behind you and be a reliable source
of peace for
you promise to stand beside you to walk
behind you and to be a reliable source
of peace for you okay that's nice words
I like that I promise to show you my
love through my actions words and
thoughts together our lives are great
and the sky is
Liv I love you and I'm happy to
be no birds baby um uh Sydney um this
has been it's been a hell of a ride um
it's been and the way we met was very
unorthodox uh our relationship is very
unorthodox you're wearing a wedding ring
now because yeah I I I found out you
were a single mom and I still got with
you even though I think getting with
single mom is a waste of time and I've
been lying to everyone about the fact
that you're a single mom it's been a
wild ride it's crazy how much would been
lying about who you are and what you've
done your age everything else because
you're actually much older than I
originally claimed
but I lie because I have an image to
maintain because well there you go
you've been wearing it for seven a half
years
but you know like I said you you I I
bring out the best in you um but you
make me happy you really do um I was
happy before you you know what I thought
he was going to say I thought say I
bring out the best in you but uh you
don't really bring out the best of me I
do that myself I bring out the best of
me
I for got the best out of you and cuz
listen I don't really need you I just
need my homies cuz men and women can't I
don't know
just
the that's what it makes me think
of for S years
but you know like I said you you I I
bring out the best in you um but uh you
make me happy I like how it start with
you you you I bring out the best in
you it sound like he was about to
compliment her and he went and then it
doesn't I make you better
stupid um I was happy before you um and
if you and I decide to part ways for
whatever reason I'll be happy without
you I don't care what nobody says there
is never a day in life where you can
convince me this is not the most loser
as [__] ever you want to love the woman
that you love and share these kind of
weird vows and that's F doing this for
Content doing a Q&A afterwards doing
vows where you're s like yo I was happy
at before you and I'm going be happy
after you it's like holy [__] but I'm
happy about the way you made me happy
because I made you that's C that's a
crazy bar that's a crazy bar I was happy
before you I'mma Be Happy after you but
I'm happy to be with you
because I made you where you
going yo dead ass when red pill dudes do
marriages I feel like it got to be like
this yo listen I'm killing it did you
did you bring it a whole L I'm killing
it baby did you bring a I made you I
[__] I did
everything hey look at me I marry me
baby I pronounce us me and
me for eternity you wasn't about to kiss
your oh oh I kiss myself every night how
can I not you ever catch a mirror and
catch a reflection when you a red pill
man you got to love it
hey blue pill beta [__] and I've
never really had someone like you I
really haven't um I'm glad that I I'm
glad that I made you into the woman you
are today um and I'm glad that
you continue to hold that standard
um success is success is really really
cool to have to be financially
successful but it's much much sweeter
when you have someone like you to share
with and so by the power best than me I
pronounce us man and wife did he say man
and wife did he say that yeah cuz he's a
man cuz he doesn't want to be a husband
no cuz that would be
simpish that's Logic No but if that's
your wife then you're her husband I
don't even understand that no really
really cool to have to be financially
successful but it's much much sweeter
when you have someone like you to share
with and so by the power bested in me I
pronounce us man and
[Applause]
[Music]
wife
bad okay so so now that we're uh
officially married I guess we'll take
questions from the audience we're going
to do 10 minutes of questions then we're
gon it's a skit it's a skit no question
questions at the end of your wedd
anybody got questions yo when is the
last time you bang other question is she
going to be your only one no it's I
think I think this is his viewers I
think this is an event he red his
viewers probably that that see that I
can get behind that hey you know what I
will say this is innovative I have never
heard of a wedding with a
Q&A but in this content driven world
even this is not surprising I mean if
y'all [__] hate Mar so much then just
don't do it I I don't understand this
like okay jokes aside and laughing at
how stupid this guy looks like red build
dudes complain about marriage all the
time I would never get the state
involved yada yada yada yada yada
okay then what's the point of Y getting
married you guys are not getting married
in a religious context you're not
getting married in a governmental
context what the [__] you're not even
getting married in front of friends and
family to like see families United
you're doing this in front of
subscribers what the [__] is the point
of
this is your are you are you going to
announce your wife what's the point to
your audience just just tell her she's
your wife and that's it well your thing
is just
that I don't know know it's their
universe so you're presenting your wife
in front of your universe so therefore
why
not bro I'm trying so going so so okay
so stop laughing I'm trying this is a
serious matter you stop laughing but
yeah yeah yeah you can't tell me to stop
laughing if you're laughing go ahead
okay
so I can't now I'm giving you a choice
Neil in this hand you have the blue pill
Oh my days or you have Donovan
sharp the blue pill will plug you back
into the we're good we're good we're
good we're good we're good we're good
we're good listen to my options you know
what I don't have to I don't have to
choose blue pill or red pill I don't
have to choose no pills why am I on the
pill are they are are they happy they
look happy so good for them good for
them good for them since y'all want to
sell this lifestyle to other people it's
okay for folks to laugh at it it's okay
especially when you say your lifestyle
is better than others especially when
you say your way is the truth your way
is the red pill whatever the [__] it is
like it's okay for people to look at you
guys and say y'all goofy as hell D I'm
not out here looking for people's
wedding ceremonies like what the [__] is
but this I treat this a bit different
the only thing I'd be wondering is like
why do these dudes who say they have the
truth and all this stuff just end up
looking like such DWS and losers like
they look like the kind of social
rejects you never want to socialize with
but they're convinced that they lead the
best lives ever there are a certain kind
of
nerds you know when they get together
and they they believe in that you know
it's like uh not cosplay but um RPG yeah
that's what they doing role playing that
that's that's that's the whole universe
is what is that they builds a Persona
and then they just interact with each
other what do you guys think in the
comments below how much do you guys want
to red pill with we are selling mirrors
so if you want to get married you know
we're selling mirrors now
hey we're selling mirrors now y'all need
to know who it is that y'all going to
marry and y'all need a good reflection
to know and who you going to marry me
that's what it felt like that's what it
was